Hello! Have you ever wondered, do blind birds
can navigate?
Welcome to monthly mailbag,
where we answer science questions
from the comments section.
Seris Efthimiadis asked this one after watching
Jim Al-Khalili’s Discourse on quantum biology.
It’s a fantastic question and I’m not
sure there really is a definitive answer to,
but let’s dive in and see if we can peck
away at an answer.
We all know birds are amazing navigators.
Think of the massive migrations of Canadian
Geese, thousands of kilometres every year
across North America. Or the homing ability
of pigeons.
In fact pigeons are probably the best studied
and most impressive navigators, so lets focus
on them for today.
Pigeons can find their way back across hundreds
of kilometres of totally unfamiliar territory.
How do they do it?
It turns out to be pretty complicated and
scientists think pigeons use a whole toolbox
of senses and strategies, many, but not all,
of which do rely on functional eyes. But first,
to understand what’s going on, let’s break
down navigation:
There are two key parts of navigation: determining
where you are in space, a map, and which determining
direction is which, a compass.
You then need to constantly update those two
things to make sure you are where you think
you are and you’re going where you think
you're going.
So let’s imagine dropping a bird off at
the Eiffel Tower in Paris, 342km from the
Ri in London. How will it get home?
Our bird's never been to Paris, so there’s
no chance of it navigating just by visual
landmarks it might recognise. Which is what
we think pigeons usually do. So how is it
going to get home?
First, the compass we talked about. Birds
use two major sources of information: the
position of the sun and the stars in the sky,
and magnetoreceptors in their eyes. Both of
these mechanisms depend on working eyes at
least to some extent, so it’s not looking
very good for Seris’ blind birds.
The sun can act as a compass for pigeons because
they have a very accurate internal clock,
so they can tell which direction is which
based on the position of the sun or the stars
in the sky. Scientists have been able to test
this ability by artificially making birds
change time zones. They turn lights on in
the middle of the night and they turn them
off during the day. Birds that have been time-shifted
like this will get their directions wrong,
but not randomly, they'll get them wrong in
a very predictable way.
For example, if home is due west and it is
6pm in their head, then they’ll expect the
sun to be, let’s say, 20 degrees above the
Western horizon. So they’ll fly towards
it. But if they’ve been time shifted so
that it’s actually 10am and the sun has
recently risen, they’ll fly East, in exactly
the wrong direction.
But if it’s cloudy, then even time-shifted
birds navigate just fine, so we think the
pigeon’s first option is the sun compass,
and then they resort to using their other
senses, including magnetoreceptors in their
eyes.
Now THIS is cool…
There’s a type of protein called cryptochrome
that lives in the retinas of a lot of birds.
And it's reactive to blue light. So what scientists
think happens is that when blue light hits
cryptochrome, it becomes “active” and
will remain so for a little while until it
deactivates again. The amount of time that
it stays active is affected by the strength
of the Earth’s magnetic field. And cryptochrome
is also known to affect the sensitivity of
the retina. To see what that might look like
to a bird, let’s go to the roof.
So what scientists think happens is that when
a bird looks South, dark patches align over
their vision, kind of like this.
As they look around, the patches move too,
giving a constant sense of compass direction.
We also have cryptochrome in our eyes, but
the molecule that lets it stay active for
long enough to be affected by the magnetic
field, superoxide, is toxic, so the antioxidants
in our eyes lock it down too quickly. Researchers
think we’ve traded longevity for magnetovision.
So our pigeon in Paris is going to be able
to orient itself pretty well, as long as it’s
not blind, Seris. It knows where North is,
but how does it know that London is North?
How does it build itself a map? It’s still
kind of an open question, but we do have some
more clues. It's either more magnetoreception
or odour maps.
Apart from the cryptochrome in their eyes,
pigeons also have magnetite, a biologically
formed, iron-rich material that reacts to
magnetic fields, in their heads. Exactly where
is still a matter of some debate - it could
be in the skin on the top of their beak, near
their nostrils, or between their brain and
their skull. But in any case we’re pretty
sure it sends signals to the brain via the
trigeminal nerve, which is the same one that
controls the eyes, so if Seris’s blind birds
have nerve damage, this method won’t be
of much help.
Tiny particles of magnetite get aligned to
the Earth’s magnetic field, just like needles
in this demonstration from our museum. The
mini compasses will align to the strong magnetic
field imposed by this bar magnet. So imagine
the pigeon’s beak is full of micrometre-sized
compasses, each a fraction the width of a
human hair.
So that works fine as a compass, but it can
also work as a map. The way they all get aligned
will tell the bird where it is on Earth, because
of a concept called a gradient map. The intensity
of the Earth’s magnetic field varies with
distance to the poles, being stronger near
the poles and weaker near the equator, so
that gives latitude information. But the field
also varies in inclination, being vertical
at the poles and horizontal near the equator.
And it's the combination of these two things
where the bird can build a bicoordinate system.
Intensity and inclination vary across the
world and there's a unique set of values for
any given point on Earth.
The bird builds up a feeling for the magnetic
field at home and how it changes when it moves
in various directions. It then extrapolates
that local map out, assuming the pattern will
continue to cover the rest of the Earth.
It turns out that this magnetite map probably
only works on a very local level, up to 15km
or so, or at very large scales, 50km or more,
because in small areas variation caused by
the metal content of underlying rocks is too
localised to be extrapolated very far, and
in contrast the gradual change in the Earth’s
magnetic field can only be reliably sensed
at very long distances.
There’s also some suggestion that pigeons
can extrapolate familiar prevailing smells
in similar ways, to build up an olfactory
map. But it’s unlikely that this can create
the kind of gradient map that could reach
as far as Paris, so it’s probably restricted
to creating more of a pungent mosaic of the
bird’s home town. Useful when the journey
is nearly over, but not so great for setting
a course 300km away.
So to wrap this all together, let’s return
to our brave pigeon’s voyage. He sets off
from the Eiffel Tower and starts looping around,
getting his bearings. He quickly realises
he doesn’t recognise anything around him
in this strange and foreign land. So he checks
the position of the sun against his internal
clock and cross-references that with his perception
of the Earth’s magnetic field to calibrate
his compass.
He has a sniff but doesn’t recognise the
cheesy smells of France so extrapolates what
he knows about the large-scale gradients in
the Earth’s magnetic field to place him
on a basic mental map, and sets off roughly
in the right direction.
As he crosses the Channel small cues from
his olfactory map confirm he’s heading in
the right direction as he catches the unmistakable
pong of England. He speeds up. He hits the
Thames and can see the Shard poking up in
the heart of London in the distance. He picks
up those familiar tinglings of the local magnetic
field variations, and in no time he’s found
his way back to the warm embrace of the Royal
Institution.
But he used his vision and his eyes an awful
lot there. So to answer the question once
and for all, do blind birds can navigate?
No, probably not.
Thanks for watching. If you have a science
question that you always wanted answered make
sure to pop it in the comments below and if
you enjoy our videos make sure to subscribe
for a new one every week.